fait peur en fait vous assumez votre
part de féminité away complètement et on
va le faire alors interview alors
alors mme erickson est-ce que vous
portez des strings programme à la place
des bons vieux slip kangourou
non s ensuit boba qu'est ce que c'est
que cette histoire vous jouez à des
cinémas la ligne de ce lit parce que
j'en étais très beau je t'ai vu en photo
dans le times la valiha line la ligne la
ligne de sous vêtements
il présente tous les soirs est ce que le
soir avant de vous coucher
vous mettez une crème de nuit absolument
il a su lui dire il faut conduit à
nommer en a il faut durer le matériel il
faut que ça dure
est-ce que vous épiler le maillot de
quoi le chat quand même pas mais c'est
pas moi est de 90 ans la raison un vous
rasez sous les bras maintenant je
m'épile parfois un peu le dos ouais
quand vous êtes sur la plage est ce que
vous rentrez votre maillot de bain dans
la raie des fesses pendant un bronzage
intégral
non mais marie par exemple de nager en
rentrant le maillot ans dans les dents
les tests pour que l'eau est rationnée
magnifique dans paris match il est
magnifique
est-ce que par principe je ne couche et
jamais le premier soir non par séquences
d'antan week-ends on est plein de
vêtements au cas où il y aura un
changement de temps oui si on est déjà
simulé au lit si vous assumez votre part
de féminité vous simulez au lit mais là
c'est une part de féminité que je peux
pas assumer c'est que d'accord le passé
je passais minutes je vous ai déjà
prétexté une migraine pour pas faire
l'amour oui les geignards et crème des
migraines mois il n'est pas comme vous
quand vous faites les boutiques cinq
enfants pour les faire à deux j'ai fais
pas les boutiques vous êtes nuls en
créneau très fort au créneau ab dont
vous assumez votre part de féminité sais
pas qui a trop de foot à la télé quand
même c'est vrai que malheureusement
alors là je suis pas un mode les films
porno c'est vulgaire n'ont toujours
finement trop gros plan un endroit non
vulgaire non non il est ce assez bien le
dispensable penser parfois chirurgie
esthétique lembeye ah ouais ouais mais
je ne ferais pas mais je pense je pense
très souvent les saints par exemple tu
as raison il est parti de jean marie fut
à peine
est-ce que vous pensez que la chose la
plus importante dans un couple c'est la
confiance finalement c'est féminin ça
c'est pas féminin ça ouais alors si
c'est féminin 1
c'est féminin c'est pratique voici en
tout cas je trouve que c'est très
important ça vous gêne le faire l'amour
avec la lumière allumée parfois non moi
j'aime bien ça l'après midi en plein jeu
on a là un parc
excusez moi je me suis révélé que l'on
croyait les tuileries vous aimeriez vous
faire un piercing au nombril il joue
strinberg via la télé où en est la
société mère de liège n'est pas conduite
mans n'ont bien vous aimez bien qu'on
vous invite au resto ouais c'est
important de premiers baisers pour vous
c'est fondamental à